bonjour la bienvenue aujourd'hui on va
revenir sur la vidéo 26 sur un tir ans
artificielle qui paraît des cinq
scénarios catastrophes causées par une
ia et je fais un petit peu des bunkers
quelques conneries que j'ai dit mais
j'ai aussi c'est aussi l'occasion
d'insister sur certain poids qui en fait
sont souvent illustrative d'un phénomène
plus fondamental donc voilà donc il a
l'idée de base de ces cinq scénarios
secteur scott il est vraiment
fondamental de chacun des scénarios
c'est de faire des scénarios dans lequel
il n'ya pas de méchants
vraiment on a des gens qui veulent
finalement bien faire globalement mais
où en voulant bien faire on arrive quand
même à mal faire et à faire des
scénarios qui sont finalement assez
catastrophique
tout ça pour insister sur un fait c'est
que l'intelligence artificielle et cette
question de la morale d intelligence
artificielle c'est un problème très
difficile et je pense que c'est vraiment
ce que j'essaie distri à travers ses
cinq scénarios c'est pas tant qu' il
soit réaliste ou pas ça à mx et
secondaires et les trucs complètement
pas réaliste dans ses vidéos ce qui
semble intéressant c'est de voir comment
les choses peuvent dégénérer
pour des raisons qui ne sont pas
quelqu'un et méchant ou liées à de bien
méchante
parce que dès qu'on tombe un petit peu
dans cette vision un peu manichéenne du
monde
on a tendance à penser qu'il suffit de
ne pas être méchant d'une gentille pour
résoudre ce problème
alors qu'en fait comme j'ai dit
plusieurs fois la preuve d'un moral
désir c'est un problème qui est
incroyablement difficile que me disait
de boston c'est sans doute l'un des plus
grands défis de la prochaine génération
de mathématiciens voir en fait de la
génération du mathématicien
d'aujourd'hui ah oui j'ai oublié bien
sûr je vous recommande d'aller voir la
vidéo avant de regarder cette vidéo si
ce que je vais pas vous montrer toutes
les vidéos précédentes et dans cette
vidéo juste certains extraits que qui
sont intéressants et du coup aller voir
la vidéo précédente
avant de regarder que celle là ok donc
ce que j'avais en en bas c'est juste
juste revoir ma vidéo et vous donner mes
petits commentaires en temps réel de ma
vidéo allez c'est parti
l'appareil de pas mal choses très
sérieuses de l'article de turing 2950
opaque learning en passant par la
régression logistique ou la cpa là quand
je fais du site d'animateurs dynamiques
j'essaie de montrer que je suis
intelligent pour pour dire aux gens
m'ont baba s'est pas non plus
complètement détruit complètement débile
que avoir plus de la science fiction
et puis le mec qui raconte ses histoires
peut-être pas trop débile parce que j'ai
fait perdre cette introduction qui
conçoit alors un robot simpliste capable
de séduire les hommes japonais à ces
histoires de robot sexuel alors au début
il faut savoir que le scénario était
vraiment orienté bien sûr le sexe est en
fait savoir qu'il a team est rendu
compte que bon c'est qu'un petit peu
poussé le bouchon trop loin et du coup
je suis juste ramené à des robots
séducteur sont pas forcément sexuel mais
en fait c'est pas vraiment ce que
cherche à illustrer ces épisodes pas
vraiment de sexe l'idée vraiment
important de cet épisode c'est que
l'intelligence artificielle
c'est quelque chose qu'on aime en
attendant sa présentation ce
artificielle qu'on le dit explicitement
comme quelque chose de dangereux
méchant skynet terminator et tout ça
mais avant tout voilà si je prends mon
téléphone qui est en train de filmer
donc je peux pas le sortir la poche mais
mon téléphone c'est un truc je suis
addict à mon téléphone aujourd'hui je
sais c'est fou à quel point je suis
addict à mon téléphone et je suis pas le
seul je vois les gens dans le métro bas
les gens sont tous sur leur iphone on
est tous vraiment devenu addict quand le
téléphone est l'une des raisons
principales pour lesquelles c'est
difficile de se débarrasser mention
sortie elle c'est parce qu'on ne veut
pas se débarrasser d'intelligence
artificielle on devient vraiment
dépendant de ces technologies
c'est pas juste de la dépendance est
vraiment qu'on aime ça on a envie de
vivre avec
étant principalement intelligence
artificielle en fait sans qu'on n'a pas
cette peur qui est explicite et qui te
rend vraiment compte
en fait on est complètement aujourd'hui
dépendant d intelligence artificielle
est juste on adore la ligue way you tube
et les vidéos qui nous recommandent les
robots love tendo exige par exemple
qu'on leur offre des cadeaux pour rester
de bonne humeur
un petit bouquet de fleurs à 2 euros et
le robot love tendo ne fera pas la tête
toute la soirée
un joli collier à 50 euros et le robot
love tendo sera pleine de joies et de
fous rires
à la grande surprise de kimi ceci rend
les robots love tendo d'autant plus
attrayante aux yeux des clients
le sit in est assez intéressant dans cet
épisode c'est le fait qu' on a tendance
à aimer ce qui n'est pas trop facile je
pense qu'il ya vraiment de ça
actuellement dans les jeux vidéo en fait
voilà typiquement une fois que vous avez
fini de me pepper clip c'est fini et que
les trombones et
loewe devient chiant et c'est une serre
manière c'est grand le jeu intéressant
et je pense que ces cas dans pas mal de
jeux c'est le fait qu'il y ait des
contraintes des difficultés et que la
récompense nécessite un certain travail
quelque chose qui me parle pas du tout
alors il sent que l'idée selon laquelle
ce qui va vraiment nous plaire dans le
futur était publique qui ont vraiment
nous plaire on n'était que ce musée qui
non seulement facilite grandement nos
vies mais aussi nous posent certains des
filles certes un certain challenge avec
on va vouloir résoudre
et voilà typiquement l'idée des frimeurs
en particulier ça dans les jeux ça va ya
des difficultés on va les résoudre et
parfois on n'y arrive pas et est parfois
utilisé un petit code c'est très utile
des séries difficulté et on est parfois
prêts à payer parfois même prêts à payer
cher pour avoir ce genre de cheat codes
les humains sont tous tombés amoureux de
leur robot il s'agit d'un crèfcoeur que
d'imaginer ne plus les avoir dans leur
vie d'enfant remarque importante avec ce
premier épisode qui valable aussi pour
les épisodes 2 et 3 pour les scénarios
données 3par
c'est le fait que tout ça est tout à
fait possible avec des il ya aujourd'hui
je pense que le désir d'aujourd'hui
voilà le temps qu'on les met en
production qu on capture un peu quelques
données on n'est pas du tout au niveau
de la cei aurait des chances juste avec
les deux aujourd'hui on est capable de
faire des trucs sur complètement
addictif l'exemple le plus simple de
tout ça c'est histoire de tamagotchi
donc si vous êtes un peu jeunes
n'avaient peut-être pas comme ça mais il
ya une époque voilà on avait des espèces
de l'animal de compagnie virtuel qui
était ultra populaire au japon notamment
au japon sont vraiment à fond sur ce
genre de technologie et d'une certaine
manière on pouvait ressentir déjà une
certaine empathie
même si clairement le tamagotchi n'était
pas quelque chose de fonctions quelque
chose très sophistiquée avec un accès au
choix trop quoi ouais pas besoin de tous
ces trucs imprenable pour qu'on soit
vraiment addict à ce genre d écologie en
tout cas c'est particulièrement le cas
au japon
est ce que c'est peut-être moins le cas
ailleurs dans le monde aujourd'hui mais
ça me paraît difficile d'exclure le
calcul à la possibilité que ce genre d'
addiction pour des petits jouets
personnel surtout une fois qu'ils sont
personnalisées qui accueille nice comme
on veut qu'ils réagissent comme des
animaux de coupe
en fait face que finalement on soit très
comprenait beaucoup d'empathie envers
flore de d'objets les médias de la sonde
onesi le pays de kimberley soutiennent
unanimement la position de leurs leaders
kimberley saute sur l'occasion pour
retweeter tous les gros titres sont
donnés siens en pot quand doria à chaque
fois doria réagi en insultant kimberley
suivie le lendemain par tous les médias
de sa syldavie natale terme à une
référence politique comme vous l'avez
deviné derrière tout ça mais bon c'est
pas si important l'idée c'est vraiment
que voilà les hommes politiques
longtemps mais ils seront pas d'accord
c'est comme des c'est comme n'importe
qui sur twitter normand fini un petit
peu par s'engueuler mais toutes deux
reconnaissent qu'il leur serait
dangereux de prendre publiquement
position pour un apaisement de la
situation
après tout toutes deux sous des
politiciennes élu par le peuple et le
peuple ne veut pas apaisé la situation
une idée que j'ai essayé de pousser
scellier sur laquelle nos mène aux
olonnes c'est votre boulot si ma vidéo
sur les incentives faut cependant que
les hommes politiques
elles sont pas gentils ou méchants
fondamentalement sont que 15 après un
modèle de mesquite est en tout cas et
cherche avant tout à être et rester au
pouvoir et ils peuvent même être
s'asseoir bienveillant donc là je prends
même le cas d'exemple de deux
politiciennes qui sont gavés entraîneur
influente puisqu'elle veut éviter avant
tout une guerre qui serait vraiment
catastrophique et à s'en rendre compte
et tel quel sans compter un peu tard
mais elles sont un peu dépassées non pas
par qui qui confient qu'elles ont eues
centrale parce que ça allait mais si ça
peut être surpassée mais le gros
problème c'est quand ça ça prend une
ampleur démesurée que tout le monde se
sont concernés par ce prêt mais que du
coup le peuple commence sur twitter où
les gens sont toujours très gentil sur
twitter commence à prendre des camps et
à faire enfler la situation et à vouloir
un conflit ouvert
kimberly va même jusqu'à offrir à doria
une flotte de drones tueurs des
démonstrations à la télévision de drones
qui tuent des animaux calme alors les
peuples sont donnés
et s'il daf alors les robot tueur ça
c'est un vrai c'est un vrai problème
c'est vraiment un des trucs qui me fait
vraiment flipper moi personnellement et
c'est pas une technologie à une
technologie qui existe déjà et qui est
déjà mise en place et qui est déjà
applicable et en particulier a donc il
ya des reportages des ex-cadres au
portage compte que la chine a déjà une
flotte de deux drones que les états unis
travaillent également sans doute sur ses
drones tueurs
ça c'est des armes incroyablement
flippante cas il ya une vidéo pendant du
future of life institute qui parle
vraiment de ça et c'est vraiment chez le
mouvement par exemple effectué waltz
with homme qui cherchera à promouvoir
l'altruisme et efficace vraiment l'une
des priorités c'est essayer de faire en
sorte que ces robots tueurs soient
légiférer ou du moins soit un minimum
réguler ou voir soit complètement
interdit parce que c'est vraiment une
arme incroyablement dangereux si on est
capable de tuer n'importe qui juste en
et en un coeur sur un bouton parce que
c'est vraiment ça l'objectif d'un drone
tueur c'est juste on appuie sur un
bouton et des brunes qu on partira quand
tu es la personne c'est une arme qui me
fait incroyablement peur et surtout avec
l'intelligence artificielle aujourd'hui
il fait donc contrôler tout le monde
doit punir les gens en temps réel j'ai
vraiment peur que aujourd'hui on ne
prennent pas la mesure du danger que
représentent les drones tueurs
la sonde onesi remporte ce match avec un
but à la dernière minute
doria fervente supportrice de l'équipe
de foot de syldavie est folle de rage
les sudo désir aillent tous au diable
dit elle au détour d'une phrase à
l'exemple du foot l'oncle a l'idée c'est
vraiment essayé de montrer un cas d bing
où on pourra vouloir un truc à un moment
donné et peut-être que cinq secondes
plus tard en sport commence un peu plus
tard mais voilà peut-être dix minutes 8
heures en ce moment serait qu'on
exagérait mais le problème c'est que si
on a des armes létales qui sont aussi
efficaces que les drones tueurs le temps
qu'il se passe entre l'ordre que l'on
donne donc là c'est même pas un ordre
rancune est ce juste une phrase qui est
dit et qui interprétait d'une certaine
manière le moment et c'est parce qu'on
veut quelque chose on dit vouloir
quelque chose et au moment où on se rend
compte qu'en fait on voulait pas parfois
il ya rien petit délai entre ces deux là
et si ce délai est plus court que le
temps qu'il faut pour que les drones
tueurs agissent ça peut être vraiment
catastrophique et plus généralement en
fait ce que cette question posée france
que ce cas souligne c'est le fait qu' il
est important d'avoir un délai de
réflexion entre le moment où on prend
une décision
et au moment où il existe une addition
est exécuté et ça d'habitude ce délai il
existe de façon assez naturelle parce
qu'on n'a pas les technologies qui nous
permettent de passer de la décision à
son application en avant de plus de
pouvoir prendre le temps de réflexion
j'ai envie de dire mais heureusement
avec les drones tueurs tous avaient
caressé les armes qui peuvent aller très
très vite et d'un coup d'un seul comme
ça on peut regretter une décision qu'on
n'a pas vraiment prise ou qu'on a prises
juste sur le feu d'un buzz du moment et
qu'on regrette quasiment immédiatement
il me semble qu'il faut absolument
éviter ce genre de risques parce que là
on parlera de risque existentiel
vraiment ça peut être régine aussi de
généraliser qui peut être causé par ce
genre de petites impulsions momentanée
sur les quelques qu'on risque de
regretter quasiment immédiatement un
autre truc que je voulais signer c'est
sur le nucléaire donc je suis très vite
sur le nucléaire mais en fait
aujourd'hui encore beaucoup d'inquiétude
par rapport au nucléaire
notamment parce qu'en fait on est passé
très proche de guerre nucléaire à
plusieurs reprises dans leur histoire
notamment parce que il ya des bugs donc
là par exemple là le téléphone
interprété au premier degré quelque
chose qui était dit pas vraiment au
premier degré parfois c'est des bugs
encore plus débile que ça qui peuvent
conduire à l'impression que l'urss a
lancé un missile et que du coup je
saurai pyrite a répliqué avant que mais
s'il arrive ça c'est arrivé plusieurs
fois dans l'histoire des médias et c'est
un vrai risque est le fait de disposer
d'armes aussi destructives avec un temps
d'application qui est aussi court fait
que soir de risque et commentaires
souvent ça me fait vraiment vraiment
flippé et voici peut-être assez
improbable mais si ça même 1% ou 1 pour
mille de chances d'arriver dans un an
c'est quand même un risque énorme casse
et c'est vrai risque potentiellement
catastrophique qui associe une faible
probabilité mais qui est vraiment
catastrophique titre de comparaison un
pour mille c'est pas loin d'être
comparable la probabilité de mourir dans
un accident de la route
sauf que là c'est pas une personne qui
meurt dans un accident la route là ça
serait potentiellement beaucoup beaucoup
plus de gens qui mouraient à cause d'une
arme nucléaire ou des drones tueurs test
après test la thérapie génique conçu par
l'ia semblait capable de guérir toutes
sortes de cancers alors dans un scénario
3g commencer par quelque chose qui
partait bien et je pense que c'est
important aussi de souligner je parle de
scénario catastrophe est bien sûr il ya
des catastrophes dans les séries dans
chacun des scénarios mais c'est
important aussi de souligner que la
technologie c'est peut être juste un
truc catastrophique et que ça peut avoir
des bienfaits absolument incroyable par
exemple ici voilà seule fois soigné un
cancer ça pourrait soigner pas mal de
maladie si on fait pas mal de recherches
dessus aujourd'hui
en fait si on regarde les solutions
qu'on a ça soit par exemple au niveau de
la recherche en génomique ou la
recherche sur la flore intestinale et
toutes les bactéries qui sont nous on a
des systèmes qui sont incroyablement
complexe et extrêmement difficile de les
étudier avec l'usc le cerveau humain
c'est pour ça que dans ce genre de
recherches ne sont que l'intelligence
artificielle en particulier qui est
capable de croiser un nombre de données
beaucoup plus grand que le cerveau
humain avec l'intelligence artificielle
ya sans doute eu des progrès énormes qui
vont venir et donc je voulais vraiment
signalés çà dans cette vidéo que dire
voilà l'intérêt saartjie peut vraiment
sauver des vies et même sauvé
potentiellement des millions de vies
tous les ans des centaines de patients
que dure même des morts prématurées à
cause de la thérapie génique de lire
l'un de ses passions était une jeune
fille de 13 ans
son père fut dévastée alors le cas du
père dont la fille meurt ça ça va
arriver c'est quelque chose de très
important d'être unis donc qu'à soi à
soi en génomique où que ce soit donc on
emmène de la santé où que ce soit dans
le domaine de la sécurité routière par
exemple avec une voiture sans conducteur
ça va arriver à avoir des cas où des
gens vont mourir ça m'est déjà arrivé et
c'est extrêmement intéressant de se
poser la question de comment est-ce
qu'on va réagir à cela c'est très facile
de donner beaucoup trop d'importance à
ce genre de cas qui est très minoritaire
mais surtout ce qu'il faudrait comparer
ces on est utile car ici on essaie
d'avoir une vision un peu plus globale
de la société
ce qu'il faudra comparer c'est l'effet
d'utiliser ce genre de technologie
versus la solution par défaut le statu
quo qui consiste à ne rien faire et dans
le cas du statu quo aujourd'hui sur la
route qui a vu mieux de morts par an en
france
dans le cas des maladies bas il ya des
centaines de milliers de morts par an en
france une gym je n'ai pas les chiffres
exacts mais dans le monde ça se compte
en tout cas en millions ouais bon combat
faut se comparer à sa foi aussi de
prendre du recul et pas regarder son cas
particulier mais voir que dans son cas
particulier et il faut absolument
réussir à le comparer au cap le plus
global et se dire que bon on va là il ya
vraiment pas eu un rhénus un coup de
malchance parce que ça va arriver
forcément il ya des gens qui vont pas
avoir de chance à tous est à 6 il ya
même un pour cent de chances que ça se
passe mal bas et il y aura une personne
sur cent pour qui ça va mal se passer
il faut l'accepter et faut pas se poser
la question de qui ce qui serait arrivé
si on n'a pas fait ça je pense qu'il
faut plus se poser des questions
prospective c'est à dire se dire si je
devais reprendre la décision maintenant
par exemple a donc là qu'ils ont pu s'y
oppose pour son fils qu'est ce qu'il
faudrait faire et il faut absolument
éviter de surinterpréter un cas passé
c'est essayer d'avoir une vision plus
globale pour l'ensemble de toutes les
données et ses devoirs en point de
toutes ces données dans une approche
très belle scène de toujours considérer
toutes les données disponibles se
demander sur ce toutes ces données du
coup qu'est ce qui est ce qu'on a
faire et là dans le cas du père c'est
très facile de dire froid et sismique
est très facile de dire le père a
clairement il n'a pas fait des
statistiques
mais quand on est dans le flou de
l'action quand on est touché
émotionnellement et si très très
difficile de faire ce genre de
raisonnement et il ya vraiment vraiment
risqué je pense qu'il va falloir
beaucoup de communication de connexion
de qualité pour vraiment expliquer que
oui il ya des cas où ça va mal se passer
oui ça peut mal se passer pour vous pour
vos proches c'est ne pas dire
globalement ça se passera pas mieux pour
l'ensemble de la société et ça veut pas
dire que pour la prochaine fois que ça
vous arrivera dit est une grande chance
que ça se passe mal donc c'est des
points très délicat parce qu'on est très
mauvais pour raisonner avec les
probabilités mais ces choses qu'il faut
vraiment prendre en compte et c'est là
que je pense que la vulgarisation est
indispensable pour ton bien paré de ces
cas là il faut actuellement d'un bonne
vulgarisation faut que les gens aient
accès de la bonne vulgarisation est à
mon sens c'est très important d'investir
beaucoup plus haut niveau et la société
sur la vulgarisation passe juste pour
les enfants mais pour tous pour tout le
public de façon très générale le père
propagea aussi la rumeur selon laquelle
ces thérapies géniques était contagieuse
et que tous les humains étaient devenus
malades d'un nouveau cancer créée par
l'ia alors l'effet news par rapport aux
eaux
voilà là aux données médicales donc
c'est quelque chose aujourd'hui qui pose
énormément de problèmes déjà et je pense
qu'il ya déjà un énorme mouvement qui
est pas du tout alimenté par pas par les
statistiques médicales et qui va
remettre en cause beaucoup de problèmes
et c'est déjà très pratique on classer
suprême que je suis ici à dans cette
vidéo
encore une fois avec unia de neige
aujourd'hui le niveau de nuit au niveau
humaine ou supérieur c'est un problème
qui est vraiment d'actualité
mais c'est pas tellement de ça dont vous
voulez parler sur cette photo vidéo le
point qui est plus important à souligner
c'est en fait ce qu'on appelle dans le
jargon du machine learning le polonia
taxes
il attaque par empoisonnement des
données en fait qu'il est sait qu'on va
mettre des mauvaises données dans un jeu
de données et potentiellement ça peut
vraiment [ __ ] en l'air pas mal de
choses dans l'apprentissage et c'est
vraiment ça que j'ai voulu souligner ici
c'est oublier que si on apprend sur des
mauvaises données non seulement on va
mal à prendre mais en plus on risque de
même très mal à prendre les de faire des
trucs qui sont très très mauvais donc
c'est un vrai risque de poser nue à
taxer c'est un truc très récent c'est un
truc qui a commencé à être étudié était
de 2 ans et et voyez cette année en
particulier tout une si bing qui
l'appelle à dire sérieuse machine
learning qui entravent avant d'exploser
dans la plupart des beaucoup d articles
maintenant de recherche dans le domaine
s'intéressent à cette question de la
robustesse des algorithmes nos machines
horning à des données qui sont assez de
baisers comment a commencé a agi à
différentes données et c'est un problème
algorithmique absolument notre hiver et
c'est possible aujourd'hui que en effet
1 1
un humain en plus si c'est alimenter
rechute et on n'arrive pas à retracer
les sources
si jamais il arrive à rentrer ces
données dans la base de données qui est
utilisé pour faire du machine learning
par intelligence artificielle c'est
possible que ça fout tout en l'air et
c'est absolument vrai aujourd'hui
d'investir dans la recherche sur du mât
chinois ni qu'on appelle robuste à ce
genre d' attaque à ce genre de données
fallacieuse dépasser demandèrent la
commercialisation en masse de toutes
sortes de nouveaux traitements proposés
par l'ia mais aussi de ceux proposés par
d'autres tirs qui entrèrent alors sur le
marché bien sûr à la fin de l'épisode
dans des trucs sur lesquels vous
insistez c'est une idée qui pourrait y
avoir une prise de panique et que en cas
de prise de panique on risque de très
très mal agir si on n'a pas à les trucs
solide si tout le monde donne son avis
et s'il n'y a pas de filtre sur la
qualité de l'information qui est retenu
notamment pour la prise de décision
politique
si possible que l'on se mette à
autoriser un peu tout et n'importe quoi
que on saute un peu une procédure de
test parce qu'on a l'impression qu'ils
urgence sanitaire et limite ça c'est
peut-être plus dangereux encore que les
les approches d'incidence artificielle
de génomique qui était mise en place en
premier lieu par des scientifiques qui
sont souvent très concerné par les
questions de sécurité et il ya beaucoup
de mise en place de protocoles de
sécurité par rapport à toutes ces
technologies
si il ya un mouvement qui fait qu' il ya
un sentiment de panique et que c'est si
tu as ces mesures de sécurité peuvent
être outrepassée se dire qu'on n'a plus
forcément ces procédures sécurisées ça
peut être vraiment très très très grand
show potentiellement donc c'est très
important je pense dès aujourd'hui- de
préparer une situation de crise de se
mettre en place de mettre en place des
systèmes qui nous font réfléchir à ce
qu'il faudrait faire dans des situations
présentes de crise sanitaire
il ya déjà des trucs en place et sans
doute plein de choses que j'ignore sur
les la mise en place de solutions
sanitaires mises en place par le
gouvernement ou autre par contre ce qui
me semble encore très déficient
aujourd'hui s'est vue de la meilleure
communication meilleure vulgarisation de
ces phénomènes pour que le public sache
comment il devra réagir dans des
situations de panique comme sera le seul
ça pourrait être le cas à cause
d'urgence sanitaire est encore une fois
j'aurais peut-être un petit peu mais ça
c'est un regard de la très très bonne
vulgarisation qu'un dollar de
recommander les chaînes de problèmes
dans une série et de à céline piot ou un
peu pointu pour toutes ces chaînes ou
bio j'ai tout compris
tania lui c'est important que ce genre
de truc qu'on soit conscient des grands
enjeux des grandes idées de la recherche
et du coup qu'on se prépare à 40
allemand a peut-être des catastrophes
qui nous arrive virait individuellement
mais qui sont pas en fait généralisable
ou et qu'on comprenne l'habitude de
raisonner de façon plus à la fois
fondamentales et à fois plus globale
donc avec des principes plus
fondamentaux de la biologie et des
statistiques plus globale sur l'ensemble
de la population
le mathématicien gilbert david est
obsédé par les nombres premiers et en
particulier par la fameuse hypothèse de
riemann alors gilbert david c'est un
clin d'oeil en fait à david gilberte
donc un des grands mathématiciens
d'histoire du début du 20e siècle et à
david hubert de suite moins une citation
de david hubert dont je me suis un peu
par coeur je l'aï écrire ici
davy libertdeals est que s'il se
réveiller dans 200 ans la première
question qu'il posera c est ce que
l'hypothèse de riemann a été résolu et
donc c'est un énorme clin d'oeil bien
sûr à cette anecdote que ce scénario lié
à disposant désormais d'une conscience
d'accès elle se rend compte que ces
méthodes ont peu de chances d'aboutir
rafa c'est un point assez intéressant
c'est c'est là que on passe de d'unia
d'aujourd'hui est peut-être unia d'un
futur qui est pas forcément très
éloignées c'était un gars qui est
capable de mesurer 1
est-ce que c'est vraiment intéressant se
plaindre parce que c'est très difficile
de mesurer l'avancée de la recherche sur
les classes de riemann voilà n'a pas de
slider qui dit voilà on est à 5 pour 50%
de la voir évoluer non c'est pas un jour
ce sera résolu et c'est difficile de
prévoir quand mais cependant on n'entend
pas être maintien n'est capable de dire
si une idée peut être utile peut être
pertinente
est-ce qu'il faut plus soit ainsi dans
cette direction en cif opus soir c'est
dans cette direction
quels sont les outils qui seront plus
probable d'être utile à la résolution
des puzzles dimon et sadc reverse et
requiert une prescience d'accès dansant
souple non seulement faire des
tentatives que serra sera réflexion de
niveau 0 mais il faut aussi une
conscience sur ce qu'on a essayé et ce
qu'il reste à essayer et quelles sont
les pistes qu'on a essayé qu'ils sont
plus qu'ils ont mieux marché donc là
donc là il ya une notion d'inconscient
accès aux semences de la vidéo notamment
deux filles dansent ou lentilles ans
artificielle est consciente des calculs
que la fête et de l'objectif vraiment
qu'elle cherchait à atteindre est d'à
quel point elle peut réorienter ses
différents stratégie pour arriver à cet
objectif
et une fois qu'on a une ia qui fait ça
et qui notamment se rend compte qu il ya
des algorithmes et qu'elle même est un
algorithme est et que finalement il
suffit de lancer pas mal d'algorithmes
voire de voler des libres et open source
en utiliser de l'open source pour
encoder d'autres algorithmes et qui vont
initier d'autres pistes confort qu'ont à
7 mai la commission qui peut servir du
coup de mes théories sting c'est-à-dire
de quelque chose qui va choisir quelles
sont les bonnes il devance algorithme a
lancé notamment on peut facilement
mettre par-dessus système de son appel
algorithmes génétiques qui va
sélectionner les meilleures approches et
tout ça une fois que l'on a ça on est
vraiment plus très loin d'une ia
qui va se dire bon il faut que je m'auto
réplique partout sur serveur que je
teste différentes options et à chaque
fois je veux dire ses différentes
variantes de moi même rôle à qui elle
est vraiment l'objectif est comment
mesurer l'état de projet et qu'est-ce
qu'il faut chercher implémenter donc de
même métacognition ancien sait qu avoir
un truc qui il ya une question de
comment est-ce qu'on peut acquérir les
centres les droits sur l'utilisation des
centres de données de google et autres
ça c'est pas très clair dans cette vidéo
c'est un des défauts de cette vidéo mais
voilà en passant peut-être par un
ingénieur de google comme ça qu'on est
un peu plus tard dans la vidéo c'est ça
paraît pas si farfelue que dès
aujourd'hui ou du cadre d'un futur
peut-être pas si éloigné que quelqu'un
puisse programmer une ia qui se disent
qu'il faut cas ce qu'a su appliquer qu
elles l'utilisent les progrès en
intelligence artificielle pour s'auto
améliorée et ainsi peut-être sous
répliqué et avoir une incidence qui
devient de plus en plus intelligentes
un point qui du coup important dans
cette vidéo ces cas pas besoin qu'une
intelligence artificielle programmé
aujourd'hui soit super intelligente pour
que la fonction objective qu'on lui
donne aujourd'hui sont encore celles de
la première super intelligence c'est
possible que en exploitant petit à petit
elles progressent et atteignent cette
super intelligence et c'est pour ça que
dès aujourd'hui je pense que c'est ultra
important de réfléchir à la morale des
intelligences artificielles les ia de
gilbert l'avait anticipé elles ont migré
d'un centre de données à l'autre avec
des copies caché dans maintenant des
milliards de serveurs différents
à moins d'une extinction coordonnées de
tout internet une reconstruction de
toute l'infrastructure informatique
saisir seront tels des pires us dont les
ordinateurs ne pourront pas se
débarrasser débrancher internet
c'est quelque chose d'assez intéressant
parce que une critique qui me semble
assez naïve de l'intelligence
artificielle général dangereuse c'est
que vous suffit de la débrancher
mais voyez que déjà avec cet exemple si
on à unia qui se réplique dans le
serveur elle agira comme un virus
informatique et se débarrasser d'un
virus informatique
c'est déjà très difficile alors imaginez
maintenant à vias informatiques qu'ils
soient arrêtés l'union
ça paraît très difficile de s'en
débarrasser si à cela implique partout à
travers internet et arrive à se cacher
dans dans des des cartes mémoires sur
des téléphones d'intel qui traînent dans
un entrepôt où je suis pas trop ou que
quelqu'un a ajouté j'essaie pas trop que
téléphone que quelqu'un a perdu dans la
mer il y aura un tueur quelques parcs
des traces de cette incidence artificiel
et sera très difficile de la supprimer
complètement et du coup là là on sent
que la seule façon ça sera vraiment du
thouraud partir à zéro mais tout
recommencer à zéro c'est ultra coûteux
pour les sociétés aujourd'hui on est
ultra dépendant de notre technologie
aujourd'hui si on est à internet
il est tellement de catastrophes qui
vont venir assez rapidement puisqu'il ya
plein de systèmes de gestion de
l'énergie et réciter des transports des
réservations des dépôts cession des
biens des contrats immobiliers ou ce
contre quoi il ya tellement de trucs qui
passe aujourd'hui par internet que
couper internet c'est une catastrophe
mondiale
c'est pour ça que je pense qu'ils ont un
talent certain officiel dès aujourd'hui
qu'ils commenceraient à ceux appliqués
un peu partout et qu'il chercherait à
qui ferait quelque chose de mal je
serais déjà qu'il y aurait un incident
quelque chose de très viral
tant qu'il y aura un instinct de survie
en france où elle a vraiment un objectif
atteint elle veut vraiment atteindre cet
objectif est assez que pour atteindre
cet objectif
bayrou ya que l qui veut vraiment cet
objectif du coup faut absolument qu est
l elle survivre qui est ça c'est ce
qu'on appelle encore une fois à un
objectif instrumental convergent s'il
n'ya veut cet objectif dès aujourd'hui
ça me paraît déjà très difficile de la
supprimer
aujourd'hui on vous faudra utiliser des
moyens algorithmique pour combattre
cette intelligence artificielle est
sympa déjà très dangereux quoi donc ses
idées de danse et danse artificielle qui
s'auto réplique qui tue qui qui qui
envahissent tout internet
en fait ça me paraît pas si éloignées et
ça me paraît extrêmement dangereux les
ja découvre alors un dossier très
compromettants sur l'un des ingénieurs
de google et le menace de révéler ce
dossier elles font chanter c'est un
génie
heures et le force à révéler un mot de
passe qui donne accès à toutes les bases
de données de google assassiné minéraux
marque concrètement sa ligne et que
l'intelligence artificielle truc
purement électronique ça peut pas avoir
d'effet sur le monde physique
là ce que je veux vraiment montrer c'est
que en fait il est largement avoir plus
d'impact sur le moins de physique
yal'idée détrônant son nez des drones
qui sont commandés qui sont reliés à
internet et qui sont contrôlables à
distance et en fait c'est ce qui se
passe
elles sont contrôlables par vos
téléphones et du coup un signe
d'intelligence artificielle de arrive un
peu à quai les les
les droits sur l'application android ou
si juste passer android eu lui-même qui
veut contrôler le drone il peut le faire
que faire donc ton plaisir peuvent déjà
contrôlé donnent aujourd'hui elles
peuvent ou des zones déjà accès aussi
aux un film en 3d et peuvent 3,3 des
plantes et des trucs qu'ils des objets
connectés qui vont pouvoir faire
différentes interactions et puis petit à
petit on pense avoir décidé au robot qui
sont contrôlables à distance
si vous connaissez pas il ya la chaîne
est en fait l'entreprise même boston
dynamics qui fait énormément de tels
robots clairement attirance artificiers
aujourd'hui à énormément de conséquences
très pratiques sur la vie des gens pour
conséquence dans mon physique que
peuvent avoir les insolences artificiel
c'est tout simplement en faisant en
agissant sur les humains aujourd'hui
youtube agit sur tellement de gens en
proposant certaines vidéos plutôt que
d'autres et peuvent changer du coup
l'opinion des différentes personnes
juste en choisissant quelle vie doit à
quelle vidéo et guillaume a exposé ses
différentes personnes donc l'iac a aucun
effet sur les humains ça c'est
clairement une idée qui déjà très
largement fausses aujourd'hui elle
produisit des robots qui à leur tour
construisirent des machines qui à leur
tour construire des usines capables de
fabriquer toutes sortes de biens de base
se loger s'habiller se nourrir et se
divertir et est désormais en libre accès
aux utilitariste année le raid est assez
intéressante que j'ai maintenant à voir
si c'est que si on y réfléchit en fait
c'est l'argent possible que tout toute
la production de biens tout du tout ce
qui est nécessaire en tout cas pour rire
et pour bien vivre puisse être
entièrement automatisé et qui
peut-être pas ça c'est un avenir un peu
plus longtemps cette cinquième 5ème
scénario c'est vraiment une ia
surhumaine donc c'est pas pour tout de
suite mais c'est peut-être pas si
distants thuyas d'avoir en tout cas une
très grosse proportion de l'industrie
qui permet de produire la plupart ou
même des services gestion des services
qui permet de produire la plupart des
trucs que l'on trouve satisfaisant pour
vivre c'est très largement possible que
beaucoup de ces industries soit
largement très automatisé dans un avenir
proche
l'ia se rendit compte que ces objets
créés par l'homme n'était pas toujours
fiable un humain qui prenait un vélo
construit par un humain avait une
probabilité d'un sur un million de
chuter suite à un ennui mécanique et les
programmes informatiques des humains il
était plein de bugs
donc ça c'est un point aussi additionnel
c'est le fait que l'argument principal
pardon pour les voitures autonomes
c'est pas tant le fait que ça va réduire
le travail non c'est surtout que c'est
moins dangereux et que ça permet de
garantir plus de sécurité et en fait ce
sera sans doute le cas de beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
technologie tuant sortir dans les années
à venir
typiquement exemple à la chirurgie
pourraient être en grande partie
maintenant fait assister par des robots
et peut-être petit à petit si un robot
chirurgien et fait moins d'erreurs qu'un
robot levant bah moi je n'hésite pas une
seconde j'ai envie d'être en bonne santé
c'est ma priorité je vous fera soigner
par le robot chirurgien la recherche on
dire progresser ailleurs dans le monde
elie à utilitariste annese craignent
qu'une ia alternative soit une menace au
bonheur des utilitariste honneur soit
6,1 points assez important à retenir
c'est que si unia veut vraiment
atteindre son objectif et elle est
programmée pour avec cet objectif donc à
veut forcément attendre autant que
possible cet objectif fait une de ses
priorités c'est éviter la compétition
c'est encore une fois de ses objectifs
instrumentaux qui apparaît c'est le fait
que pierre chose qui puisse arriver à
unias et d'être surpassé par une autre
yard et du coup il risque fort d'y avoir
une course désir et du coup c'est serré
pour ça que c'est super important que la
première ya deux niveaux humain soit
absolument déjà avec une fonction
d'objectifs avec laquelle toute
l'humanité sera d'accord
et qu'ils soient pas plus confiné à une
portion une petite proportion de
l'humanité
il se met à produire des romans des
musiques des films et des vidéos youtube
à coups de comédie et de belles
histoires
oui je suis assez curieux de voir tout
le matériel artistique qui pourraient
être créés par les ja qui pourront
générer des épisodes de black mirror en
mieux sur mesure individualisé faire je
sais que rémois de vos devoirs lors de
ce fruit qui émergeait parce qu'il ya
une super ambiance et fille des autres
des méchants et quand ça ne suffisait
pas elle fit des autres des mauvais mois
petite référence à la lidho tennessee
fille qui est vraiment génial je
recommande encore vivement ces vidéos
sur la philosophie morale descriptif de
de nietzsche qui est vraiment importante
à comprendre parce qu'on a tendance à
traiter le clan opposé soit de méchant
si on considère qu'ils ont fait ils sont
plus que nous soit de mauvais si on
considère qu'ils ont moins que mais dans
les deux cas c'est ça correspond à
essayer de d'enlever toute possibilité
d' empathie pour le clan opposé essai
c'est ça me paraît extrêmement dangereux
comme comme approche
il ne restait plus qu'à perdurer dans le
temps les images c'est le film qui m'a
fait le plus flipper je regardais tout
seul une nuit à 3 heures du matin
c'était fou c'est dur et c'est vraiment
un truc qui me fait flipper en fait le
fait qu' on se retrouve complètement
dépendant de trucs qui a en fait dont on
ne veut pas aujourd'hui mais dont on
sera complètement dépendants dans
quelques années
c'est difficile de dire que c'est pas
facile d'avoir des arguments pour dire
que ce mal ce qu'on voudra plus tard
passé c'est à ces contrats types parce
que souvent on a tendance à dire que
plutôt que maintenant ça va penser qu'on
va progresser moralement c'est à dire
que je sais pas les trucs qu'on veut
aujourd'hui sont plus morale en un
certain sens que le truc qu'on voulait
il ya 150 ans et 200 ans mais ça me
paraît vraiment pas improbable que dans
le futur ce genre de trucs
dias est une drogue qui me permet de
l'europe de mieux réfléchir être plus
moins fatiguer plus plus drôle je sais
pas
je serais vraiment envie de la prendre
si ça me permet d'être et surtout si ça
n'a aucun effet secondaire mais il ya
une défense il y as que de demeurer
après c'est tout une question assez une
dépendance qui est pas forcément une
dépendance une addiction physiologique
juste va si ça me plaît d'être danseur
d'état ça peut être difficile de ne plus
être dans cet état parce que cet état
depuis l'autre et terre étant tellement
mieux
je pense que c'est vrai que c'est des
réflexions un peu vertigineuse a qui
font vraiment flippé et c'est ainsi que
les utilitaristes année vécurent heureux
jusqu'à la nuit des temps bon bah voilà
ça finit bien ce dernier épisode c'est
un scénario tout le monde est heureux
mais ça fait un peu catastrophique quand
même ça c'est assez étrange et c'est
façon plus générale c'est assez
difficile de vouloir de savoir ce qu'on
veut vraiment classe et c'est difficile
d'écrire une utopie qui n'est pas l'air
de dystopie que vraiment vous moment
est-ce que vous ne devez écrire une
utopie zhang huan le monde il ya là quoi
il ressemblerait vous avez le droit
d'utiliser ou de ne pas utiliser déjà où
les technologies farfelues à quoi
ressemblerait un telle onde
je pense qu'on y a des trucs sur 15 est
assez d'accord fait qui est une maladie
je pense que c'est un des points et
c'est d'accord plus de faim dans le
monde où chacun a accès aux biens de
base pense que c'est un peu les trucs
sur laquelle on est là c'est assez
d'accord mais au delà de ça c'est calme
très difficile d'imaginer une utopie et
c'est assez amusant que ça soit aussi
difficile d'imaginer une utopie fait en
tant qu'humain difficile de savoir ce
qu'on veut vraiment c'est un petit peu
en fonction de ses sérieux généralement
la vidéo l'épisode 26 donc avant de la
faire je veux dire que j'étais déjà
inquiet par rapport aux 28 ans artiste n
était pas si inquiet jouer ça comme un
vrai danger existentiel beaucoup plus
dangereux que tous les autres dangers
liste en ciel dont on peut parler j'ai
fait ça me fait vraiment flipper déjà un
sens artificielle 10% de chances que ça
se passe mal
ce qui est énorme bouchon sur 10 mais
après avoir vu cette vidéo fait une
rencontre que c'est pas un problème du
futur il ya plein de trucs qui sont
venait déjà les graines d'aujourd'hui et
les graines d'aujourd'hui peuvent déjà
être pourri et pousser et donner des
trucs qui sont catastrophiques dès
aujourd'hui c'est pour ça que c'est un
problème je me suis vraiment mis un
flipper en fait après cette victoire
j'en suis et le fait qu'ils financent
très peu de gens qui se sentent
concernés par ce problème
voir tellement de chercheurs brillant et
très reconnu qui dénigrent ce genre de
réflexion ça me fait vraiment flipper
parce que nick ça donne l'impression
sera jamais prêt le moment où il faudra
être prêt donc c'est vraiment la
conclusion de ces vidéos c'est que il
faut absolument beaucoup plus réfléchira
à ce problème en soit beaucoup plus
conscience de ce prêt mais il faut
absolument beaucoup plus de recherches
pour éviter des innombrables pièges
c'est un nouveau truc c'est que c'est
pas juste un truc à éviter il ya un
nombre de pièges qui est énorme et il
faut vraiment toussé éviter et c'est ça
qui est difficile de force